i heard something recently uh that
absolutely shocked me this is a true
story apparently this holiday season
there's been a rash of thefts of
nativity scene figures it's actually
yeah a lot of stories about these are
real stories about people stealing
nativity scene figures i didn't realize
it was such a big problem oh it is a
huge problem and in fact
it's the subject of my latest shane
blamers investigative report
the latest you've never done a shame
blamers investigative report
[Music]
the traditional nativity scene
to some a symbol of the miracle of
christmas
but to the criminal underworld it's just
an easy target
i'm talking about the latest threat to
your merry christmas
nativity scene chop shops
my shane blamers team filed this
investigative report
[Music]
through their vast network of thieves
these chop shops are looting nativity
scenes stripping them for parts and
reselling them for a quick buck
some might say it's a crime worse than
murder
[Music]
meet one of their victims
every morning the first thing i do is
get up and clean my nativity scene but
this morning i went out there and my
little baby jesus was gone some criminal
must have stolen him in the middle of
the night while i was sleeping
i just want to know where my little baby
jesus is
it probably ended up at a place like
this
this legitimate looking business is
actually a front
here nativity scenes are stripped down
resold as knockoff versions of popular
holiday toys like harry potter
so how do these nativity scene chop
shops operate we brought our shame
blamers crew to find out
[Music]
well nobody's here we did our best it
was clear these criminal masterminds
weren't going to make this easy for us
so it was time for plan b
i rigged this nativity scene camel with
a tiny hidden surveillance camera
once they took the bait we got an inside
view of their illegal operation
what we found may shock you
rose upon rows of spare pumps ready for
resale
chop shop employees forced to work under
constant watch and inhumane conditions
and around the clock assembly line of
cheap knock-off holiday toys
we needed to bust their operation wide
open but when we arrived the next day
our chop shop was already long gone and
in its place was this water park
oh wait let's hear what happened to this
lady i bought my little boy one of those
robots that turns into cars and trucks
and such well when i got it home
my heart nearly burst
my name is after me stripe my name is
[Music]
shameful
well there you have it conan back to you
all right that was an incredibly odd
story andy
well to be honest most of it was made up
i really enjoy camera time okay
thank you andy richter